cannabis is an American homegrown
commodity and it's time that Americans
took ownership of it and we need the
cooperation of the federal government to
achieve that I'm dr. Christopher
Fichtner I'm a psychiatrist and the
author of a new book that's just come
out in the last couple of months called
caneva nom --ax the Marijuana Policy
tipping point the tipping point is the
real-time convergence of three distinct
policy trajectories that can be
identified if we look back over the last
well certainly the last decade and a
half but in particularly even over the
last five years we see a building
convergence of these three trajectories
what are they the first is the medical
marijuana movement began in California
really with with the 1996 law passed
here and then since that time I think 14
other states have have joined on have
various versions of a law which allows
for certain individuals to get access to
cannabis with the approval of their
doctor the second would be the
recognition of the drug war as a public
health problem in its own right in other
words the drug war as as a way of
managing drug-related issues that is
creating more public health problems
than its solving too many people
incarcerated too many people arrested
too many people in fact killed actually
and you know one of the one of the sort
of developments that's been focused on a
lot of media attention has been the drug
war in Mexico has been the violence
around the Mexican and American border
that has been an issue that's got an
increasing attention and I think you
know on a you know on a less drastic
scale perhaps but in a way in some ways
more palpable for people that are
involved in it here has been this whole
series of raids by the federal
government on people trying to you know
peacefully manage access to cannabis for
medicinal use in California cannabis
policy becomes a subset of that drug
policy problem
which is the easiest of all to address
why is it so easy to address because
there's so much use of it in the United
States
and because by comparison to other
substances that we know of cannabis just
doesn't have the same level of
dangerousness certainly not as alcohol
or tobacco certainly not you know as
dangerous as many of the prescription
drugs that the FDA has already approved
there's a growing recognition that the
way we're treating marijuana or cannabis
in this society doesn't match what we
know about the relative harms associated
with it or you know on the other side
the safety of it so the medical
trajectory is the first one the
recognition of the public health
problems associated the drug war is a
second one and a third is the economic
crisis that we're really sitting at a
time where if it's ever been clear that
drug prohibition and especially as an
easier to manage subset of that
marijuana prohibition if it's ever been
clear that that was not affordable and
was ill-advised and there are many
different aspects to that if it's ever
been clear that that's the case it's
certainly clear now and many people have
said that the normalization that the
regulation the tax and regulation the
development of a cannabis industry that
offers quality control for consumers
many people have argued that that could
be part of an overall package of a you
know of economic recovery if you look
back at the elections in November of
2006 where you had three states South
Dakota almost passed medical marijuana
48% of the vote on an initiative
Colorado almost passed a decree
decriminalization initiative similar to
what Denver had passed the year before
which is decriminalizing cannabis on the
basis of the idea that it is safer than
alcohol and 41% of the vote came through
on that Colorado trajectory and then
Nevada the same year attempted to tax
and regulate proposal much along the
lines of what California is looking at
now on a much smaller scale because
there's you know it's obviously not as
big a state but they got 44% of the vote
so there you had a medical of Public
Health and an economic trajectory
all below the radar because they didn't
get passed but they were just close
enough to passing to catch you know the
eye of somebody like me who is looking
at the field already and to say look
this is a harbinger of what we're gonna
see in can of anomic sigh used the term
incoherent as a way of describing
federal policy on cannabis and the
reason that I called it that is because
we know which compound it is that has
the greatest potential for creating
feelings of paranoia or possibly
creating hallucinations or creating you
know more impairment and you know and in
fact the feeling of being high the
euphoria and that's THC and THC has been
available as a prescription medicine
since 1985 and synthetic THC which is
ironic that they make it in the
laboratory to avoid having to extract it
from the plant and many have pointed out
more recently that extracting it from
the plant is actually cheaper than
making it in laboratory but these are
the lengths to which the government has
gone to avoid actually using that having
a legitimate use for the plant the only
the only legitimate that researched that
for the most part until very very
recently the vast majority of the
legitimate research that has gone on the
United States with the cannabis plant
has been to study it as a substance of
abuse there's a limited number of people
who do still get access to federal
growing cannabis which they say is not
very good compared to the kinds of
strains of herbal cannabis that can be
grown by in a competitive environment
where you have different people with
different ideas working on new strain
working on strains working on you know
working on the genetics of herbal
cannabis
the potential quality improvement is
much greater than what's been able to be
realized up to this point under the very
restrictive a federal cultivation for
the compassionate news program but but
that is another another irony another
contradiction in federal policy almost
no cannabis therapeutics research has
been really supported by the federal
government or even allowed by the
federal government so you have you have
the the compound THC that probably
people would be most concerned about
rated as a Schedule three drug and yet
you have marijuana in schedule one which
is illegal no medical use
obviously it has THC in it but it has a
whole array of sixty or seventy or maybe
more different estimates of how many
cannabinoid compounds plus the number of
other compounds and many people
especially in other countries now are
beginning to explore the therapeutic
value of some of those other compounds
so let's say for example CBD which is
really not associated with a high at all
per se as far as we know it does not
impair people at least the research that
I've read and there's European research
and there's Brazilian research that
finds that it actually has some
antipsychotic properties and so you know
one of my special interest issues is
that yes we know that cannabis is
helpful for nausea and vomiting yes we
know that it's helpful for neurological
pain we know that it has
anti-inflammatory properties we know
that it people find it useful for muscle
relaxation and illnesses like like
multiple sclerosis and even for things
like migraine headaches so there's a
whole variety of uses that people report
benefit in most of the states pain
management and other sort of physical
pain or physical illness uses are the
ones that are approved for you know
doctors to recommend access to cannabis
so in California really in my read is
the only state
that doesn't actively discriminate
against persons with mental illness who
are looking for it because of its anti
anxiety or mood stabilizing property are
we going to hit a tipping point this
November you know I'm going to say we're
in the process of that and I'm gonna say
yes I mean I think that everything
points in that direction more
importantly than that I think when
California does get there but whether
it's this November or later I do think
it will be this November
well when California does get there I
think the number of other states that
are gonna fall right behind it will be a
large number I think almost every state
that's approved it medically will
falling behind California very very
rapidly and I think there are other
states that are working on medical
initiatives that will stop and change it
into a tax and regulate initiative can
of anomaly to call for change not at the
state level that's already happening is
to call it's written to call for change
at the federal level for the federal
government to step in and take some
ownership not of cannabis prohibition
not a marijuana prohibition but of
regulation of access to herbal cannabis
for medicinal therapeutic and age
restricted over-the-counter access the
federal government needs to take an
active role in that because we all have
a stake in it